[Music]
hello everyone we've got another tip
2019 interview for you right now we're
talking about the movie Mosul with some
of the crew behind the movie we've got
two of these interviews up so if this
isn't enough conversation for you you
got another one coming your way soon my
first question for you guys is I was
reading the press notes this sounds like
an incredibly ambitious project and you
bring aboard a first-time feature
director so what made Matthew the right
person who direct the story um it you
know basically it started with his
passion for the material I mean all of
us we all fell in love with the original
New Yorker art or article that Luke
mogul s'en wrote where he sort of spent
time with the actual SWAT team in Iraq
and documented them and then I so that's
where I think everybody's passion for
the material came from particularly
Matt's and then secondly Matt's been one
of our favorite favorite screenwriters
for a long time now
and we had had the privilege of working
with him closely on something else so it
just all became a natural fit and when
he when he sparked the material in the
way that he did and he said that he
really wanted to direct it I think Joe
and I really we could we could feel his
energy and his focus and the intensity
of how this story was affecting him and
it just felt like something that we
should just do our best and he
campaigned very hard for it
Muhammad of course being a director as
well that we all became his support team
and in his first time directing effort I
wanted to ask you a little bit about
your history and jumping into a project
like this because I'm just someone who
greatly values a producer with
experience in so many different
departments like you have so what did
all of your experience as a director
writer cinematographer do to help you on
this particular movie it was very
important for me to be part of the the
team behind Matthew in this project and
as soon as the team has been approaching
me about Mosul and about how can we have
it so like close to home but look like
come from Mosul south it could look like
I'm from Iraq south and when I read the
script and when I when I look how Mathew
want to project in how he's honest and
he want to give right to those voice of
the policeman that tried to liberate
Mosul
Isis from - I was really tried to put
any offer I have any experience I have
to put it behind the project and to be
to be to be like so close - you feel it
like close to home and the most
important things we have it in great
great like a screening in Venice and
when the journalist came back to us and
asked us I asked a question what did he
said he saw a rocky film or an American
film and people came to me and said to
me like it's a rocky films look like
shorten it I could look like the actor
Arrakis and this is really we give a
credit to the to the to the John Anthony
and tomato and to all team behind this
project what would you say is the
biggest misconception about Mosul in
that area that you want people to know
about I think one of the for us there's
there's many things but I think is the
biggest misconception is just it's
missing the very human stories that are
happening there that's the big and that
that's why I responded so strongly to
the to the original article for years
now I've been obsessed with the news you
know Joe and I are news junkies we read
everything and you know that's been a
large part of our our work for the past
several years is figuring out how we
sort of bring these collective
experiences that we're all having
globally into our storytelling and this
seemed like an area of the world we're
really important and extreme things were
happening yet it was so hard to
understand that on human level and I
think that's partially the nature of
warfare you know the nature of warfare
is it's it's a hard place to access
because it's dangerous and restricted
and also the people coming out of a war
zone are typically leaving that war zone
because they've had awful experiences
and they oftentimes don't want to talk
about those experiences once they've
gotten out of the war zone so it becomes
very difficult to access what's
happening there on a human level and I
think that's really what this story does
in a beautiful ways it really just it
makes it so simple and relatable to
anybody around the world about what it's
like to live there and go through those
experience yeah it's tragic that so few
people actually know what is going on
there and understand it on an intimate
level and that was really the endeavor
of
project was to tell that story it's very
human story the level of destruction and
pain and suffering there is is it's
insane it's it's almost hard to
comprehend and that was something that
we wanted to convey to to audiences all
over the world I feel like I might be
getting ahead of myself with this
question because we are at TIFF for your
premiere here but what kinds of things
can you do right now to prepare to get
this movie in front of the most amount
of eyes possible also because during my
a chat with Matthew he had brought up
how this movie is being mislabeled as an
action movie so how do you get this in
front of audiences in the most effective
way one of the effective ways that we're
going to do it is because look this moot
no one has ever seen a movie like this
before I mean that is the best thing
this movie has going for it is that it
is going to be a wholly fresh experience
for you in the cinema you've never seen
this scale of a production with this
type of international crew and
collaboration collaborators involved in
the film but yet and then specifically
in the Iraqi voice you've never seen
that before and I think it's a really
revolutionary thing it's the type of
thing in that is long overdue and I also
think it's the timeless type of thing
that's only the tip of the iceberg in
terms of what types of stories are
waiting there for us to explore if we
simply open our open our open our eyes
to them and I think so the virtue of
this movie is it's going to give you an
experience in the cinema that you
literally never had I feel like there's
no one answer to this but it's on my
mind because you guys are here bringing
this movie to the public after having
had the biggest box-office hit of all
time so why is it important to you to
make sure there's that kind of balance
not just in your careers but in the
industry a movie like Avengers endgame
that really means a lot to a whole lot
of people and then these really
important true stories that you need to
bring awareness to well media is a very
powerful tool and it can be used either
negatively reinforced or positively
reinforced and and we want to use it
effectively to positively reinforce and
also just just from you know a pure
standpoint of as storytellers and
filmmakers getting to understand what's
going on there in a very intimate level
collaborating I mean I think the way
that we will we will ultimately come to
heal and understand each other on a
global scales by telling each other
stories and collaborating to tell each
other stories and that was the most
important mission of this project for us
I think just to add something muscle is
making history for American cinema
because we can say I mean I can say as a
Arabic person this is the first time in
American history we have a film to make
the Arabic character is a hero you know
it's like a hero like a normal human
being like normal any policeman in the
world this is the first film to show the
Muslim and positive side you know and
and there's the first film to be to be
to be the main character speaking their
language Arabic language and I think
this is very important step in American
history of cinema because if I ask you
our question how many film you sell
about Arabic character positive you
you're shaking your head yeah so Musa is
really a history in the top of that we
have a great story and a great black
production and and I'm telling you from
from from a filmmaker that was part of
the team to make this film I saw the
film twice in each time I'm so connected
to the store it so connected by the end
I start to cry no just like feel wow it
looked like those policemen that we are
telling because based on the true story
those policemen that they were fighting
for to liberate the city yeah it looked
like they are fighting in the name of
international community because this is
what Alec was used to tell us we are
fighting in the name of the
international community so when you see
this film you are getting justice and
this justice is very close to you so you
guys all wholeheartedly believed in this
idea being a movie just from reading the
article after you gone through this
whole process you've got a final cut is
there anything about the finished
product that pleasantly surprised you
something that you grew to appreciate
that you never
but knew you did early on I don't know
if we're surprised by it but I think the
performances are exceptional I really do
I think and I think Suhail our lead his
performance is profound in the movie
it's as good as the performances I think
you'll see this year and and I think his
story his his true story the flight from
Iraq and ending up in in New Mexico in
the US and and having to give up acting
for the most part and and then you know
playing the lead in this movie is is is
incredibly touching for us and and as
Mohammed said when we watch the film all
of that comes to bear for us as
filmmakers and producers and I you know
I cry every time I watch the movie -
because I your feeling everything that's
happening with this film from its it's
as you say a historic approach to
storytelling to the the lives of the
actors in this movie coming into the
film and coming to bear on on it with
more context with with the context of
reality and that's um you know that's
special and it's just for as a filmmaker
not something that I I don't think we'll
ever have an experience like this on a
project again I think part of the reason
why the cast is such a enormous surprise
in this film is it a lot of what
Muhammad was talking about in the sense
that these are actors these are
extremely talented actors that we went
on a global search for who have been
underutilized they haven't had
opportunities to play the rules like
this yet in big global cinema and so I
think that's part of the shock to see
them in roles to see them in leading
roles rather than sort of supporting bad
guy roles or you know sort of gay player
roles to see these people in leading
roles especially roles that they put
there and they knew what an opportunity
this movie was for them and they put
everything they had into this film so
what they do on screen is just
astonishing and heartbreaking and
uplifting and it's it's really part of
the miracle I think what this movie is
yeah and I think also the
the good things on this film also it is
not only like space in a true story but
also is entertainment entertainment in
the way that as young young people in
America or North and America come
towards this film there is entertainment
because when you get to sit and towards
this film it look like you become part
of this band of a brother part of the
team because you want to be you want
them to be successful because the
performance of the team and the acting
is so good that you feel you are very
attached so it's not only it's not only
like the the true story but also the the
entertainment that you have it through
the film from A to Z like an and one and
104 minute II don't feel at 104 minutes
because you're soft like a soldier
fighting with the team you know and try
to get to save this family try to save
the day children and you feel it you
feel it you are part of it thank you
guys so I it makes me really happy to
see people come together and make
something happen that never did before
in this industry so thank you guys for
making this movie and thank you for your
time today I really cannot wait to see
it for myself now we're gonna say
goodbye but before we do a huge shout
out to at Nordstrom Canada for making
these interviews happen thank you so
much for your support and to everybody
out there do not leave this interview
without liking and sharing it and again
another moesel interview is coming your
way or real soon so keep an eye out for
that on the Quadra video youtube channel